actuellement 5 j cl de du virus
respiratoire syncitial qui est pas le
coc u19 qui fait que plein d'enfants
qu'on les bronchiolites
oublier la covin c'est un autre problème
qui préoccupe les urgences des hôpitaux
pour enfants ce moment le virus
respiratoire syncytial le vrs je vous
dirais que probablement la majorité
au moins 115 % des patients qui
consultent à l'urgence un gsm ont ce
virus là donc on est vraiment dans une
pandémie à nous certains d'entre eux
sont très malades hier à l'aller biais
pinard après
vraiment à tous et comme un phoque comme
on dit l'expression c'est pas une bonne
touche la santé de la petite alex âgé
d'à peine un mois s'est rapidement
détérioré moi j'avais un rôle que je
crois que je lui ai donné mais elle
avait tout petit à petit un petit café
que ça se transforme en vraie qualité
puis il a besoin d'oxygène parce qu à
désaturer pas capable de respirer par
elle-même al arabia en juillet on
comptait à peine 36 cas de vrs au québec
deux mois plus tard on dépasse les 500
cas presque tous à montréal c'est
vraiment la cause numéro 1 de
stérilisation chez les enfants en bas
darna au canada donc oui c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus fréquent que l'aco vide
pour les enfants plus âgés le vrs est
rarement un problème mais pour les tout
petits c'est plus compliqué la majorité
des passagers sont des enfants avec
brooke et avec des difficultés des
troubles respiratoires et de
l'hydratation mais aussi beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont malades avec d'autres
conditions chroniques qui décompensent
justement parce qu ils ont attrapé se
hisse l'aspect a droit au total 1 à 2%
des enfants atteints seront hospitalisés
la majorité au moins d'un an autant de
cas de vrs en étaient les spécialistes
n'avaient jamais vu ça s'est passé
s'était tant d'années qui avait posté
reste presque pas d'infection durant les
derniers 12 à 15 mois la population en
général est beaucoup plus susceptibles à
cette inflexion on a eu un boom en
termes de natalité au québec pendant la
amy est donc beaucoup de jeunes bébés
qui sont nés et ont tous frères soeurs
qui vont à la garderie maintenant donc
il ramène des virus les deux hôpitaux
pédiatriques montréal est demandé aux
parents d'éviter les urgences autant que
possible histoire de laisser plus de
place aux cas graves on n'est pas sorti
du bois pagal respirer par elle-même est
on est entre bonnes mains s'agit-il ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal